all right the next point I got here is
these guys think making a million
dollars is impossible this is this is
the most contentious one this one
[__] cracks me up and pisses me off
the most I've said for quite a while now
for years I said guys when it comes to
your finances and when it comes to money
aim to be a millionaire by the time
you're 30 if you don't hit that Mark you
got to do it by
40 a million dollars when I was a kid
seemed like a lot of money a million
dollars today for me is like basically
105 million with inflation somebody can
do the exact calculation on the rate I'm
a 70s kid do the math put it in the chat
you tell
me a million dollars ain't a lot of
[__] money
today especially in large coastal cities
New York Toronto La Miami London Paris
you know any large urban city center
it's not that much money like the
average house here in the greater
Toronto area is probably somewhere in
the $700 to $800,000 range I had a
two-bedroom uh glass box in the sky
downtown Toronto I got rid of it a
couple years ago I used to rent it out
and I don't know I paid like 550 for it
sold it for close to 900 like a glass
box in the sky two bedrooms less than
800 square ft is [__] like $8 900,000
here okay like a million dollars doesn't
buy much so when people get all worked
out of shape and they're oh million
dollars rich is so let me show you
something let me show you
something I got it pulled up over here I
have a folder on my computer
okay and it's called Loser
emails so whenever some loser sends me
some dumb [__] I throw it in that
folder
right so this one ended up in loser
emails I'm just going to read it to you
it's going to be hard for you to see
title is a bit of arrogance here Rich he
says you're an honest guy I like your
videos but in return you deserve nothing
less I just watch the video Below in
which you telling people they should be
aiming to be millionaires by 30 years
old or 40 the latest this is not the
first one that I've gotten I've got DMS
I've got hate mail I've got email I've
got lots of this from these [__]
dorks by 30 or 40 the latest seriously
he says it's seems you fell victim to
your own success here rip in your own
words people who make six didn't even
spell six it's Sig people who make Sig
figure income have to be one of six
categories and each which sorry Each of
which takes time and effort to reach
that no [__]
Sherlock no [__] it all takes time and
effort it takes time and effort to build
a physique it takes time and effort to
learn combat skills I did
bi-weekly sessions for one hour for
about three and a half years of
one-on-one boxing trainer with my
training before I ever had a fight I
don't know how many hours that was hours
upon hours right two hours a week let's
do the math here two time uh what is it
52 104 * 3 312 plus the half year you're
talking well over 330 hours of training
before I even had a fight
there's time that has to go into Mastery
you don't just learn it in [__] a
month and then execute on it in a week
and like boom I'm a millionaire look at
me takes time effort to reach that after
tax and life expenses how much is Left
To Be A Millionaire
complainer not everybody has a debt
settlement business like you where she
he can have a safety that to start being
an entrepreneur without worrying about
how they're going to put bread on the
table not everyone didn't get an easy
divorce like you did who the [__] says I
had an easy divorce bro did you read my
[__] book there was a time when
I was driving down the highway where the
[__] was so up against me I wanted to
take off my seat Bel for the [__]
truck and drive into a concrete pillar
on the freway overpass to end it I
contemplated a permanent solution to a
temporary problem in my life
everybody likes to paint these [__]
stories and pictures in their head to
create these excuses as to why they're
nothing if they would invest some of the
effort that they use to create an
excuses into doing something with their
lives they'd have something to show for
themselves you have reached the point
where just mere talking in a video
generates dollars yeah that's not how it
works bro people think you just talk in
a video and YouTube sends you money I
think over the the almost 10 years I've
been doing YouTube the amount of money
that it's generated amounts to about
seven or eight% I know because I do my
[__] reviews with my accounts on an
annual basis like seven or eight% of
what I've earned in total in that year
it's [__] peanuts do you understand
just because you press the broadcast
button or you have a Channel or people
look oh he's got subscribers that
doesn't mean anything they they the
value that people think YouTube
generates is so insignificant it's like
this guy thinks that I'm that I'm rich
because of because of YouTube money
congratulations but that doesn't mean
that you belittle everybody else that
hasn't had your success
[__] your feelings are hurt I
get it I've had my feelings hurt too
bullies have hurt me girls have hurt me
I've made some bad choices I've hurt
myself everything that I get out of life
I blame myself though at the end of the
day because you are in your own driver's
seat there's these people that are like
hope well you know I just hope or I or I
just wish or if I pray enough it's like
again hope is a terrible plan it's a
worst [__] plan I just hope if I just
hope enough if I just hope strong enough
and enough times a day then money
success strong physique women are going
to be throwing themselves at me no
that's not how it
works it's it's your video is quite
condescending and misleading the part
that he's talking about which the 30 to
40y Old latest and he has a video linked
over here I clicked it and I watched it
to see where it was it's about the three
minute Mark there's a
5c statement that I made because the guy
is in his 40s and he says his net worth
is only about $300 or $400,000 and I say
guys aim to be a millionaire by the time
you're 30 or 40 at the least okay figure
that part out and I carry on that's all
I said and that's lose user which is why
he ended up in my loser email folder
takes the time to write this complaint
he wants to talk to the manager links
the video says that you're out of touch
not everybody has YouTube money or has a
success from their debt settlement
business you know [__] hard I like I
I know that some of you haven't read the
book maybe this dork hasn't read my book
there was a point in my life in my
business setting aside the the difficult
and getting it off the ground cuz the
first year to two years are like the
hardest parts of it figuring it out
navigating it legislators come at you
service providers you've got issues
there's a lawsuit or two that comes up
you got to knock out of the park there's
always some
[__] the hardest thing for
me was I think it was the eight-month
period when I was doing the
lobbying in Ontario Parliament on Bill
55 and we had to make some pivoting
changes within the business and and we
didn't have the cash
flow I had 23 24 employees I didn't want
to fire people or let anybody go cuz we
had customers to take care of and I
didn't want to overburden anybody so I
made myself from the highest paid
employee in the company which the CEO
should be to the lowest paid I I paid
myself so [__] little it was like the
bottom of the barrel I had to check with
my account I'm like what's the minimum
that I that I can pay myself to still be
an employee and still get the benefits
um so I can make sure that you know
everything else is taken care of outside
of the scope of the money that I've
resaved so I I I became the lowest paid
employee for a long period of time that
shit's [__] hard I've done a lot of
hard things in my life but I've never
complained about them this is probably
the first time I've ever mentioned it if
I'm being honest but people walk around
with this like worldview and their head
well I'm a loser I'm not I'm not getting
what I want so this guy's disconnected
from reality and I don't think he did
anything and he's just an overnight
success and he he doesn't understand you
know the plight of the average guy dude
I was the average guy I was paying rent
to my parents when I was [__] 15
years old okay when my dad moved to
England because he wanted to move the
family over there and he took three and
a half years to find a job and I was
still here as a teenager I was paying
[__] rent to my mom probably
comparable to the rate that what I would
have paid if I had my own place okay
pretty much a good chunk of my money
went to the household to take care of
[__] and I still managed to buy a
[__] motorcycle and I still managed
to
buy uh one two
three three different cars they were all
[__] boxes but I still managed to buy
cars so I could drive around and do
things but people but people want to be
victims you know oh you're out of touch
Rich you have no idea how
to you know had to talk to the common
man dude I was the [__] Common Man
The Common Man becomes the uncommon man
by doing the [__] work not by
bitching in somebody's email about being
disconnected from reality you're you're
arrogant
me what else we got here in my
notes
guys sometimes you know you're like oh
well he's mean or he doesn't understand
or he doesn't have sympathy I don't give
a flying
[__] because I had to do the
work this is something that's common
with any guy that comes from nothing and
becom something is they don't have
sympathy for crybabies and whiners
that's me you don't want to hear me say
[__] that might hurt your feelings in
2024 be better in 2024 so I don't have
to hurt your feelings
again [__] me the amount of laziness
that I come across complainers is just
off the chart I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clip's from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out